we want to establish an amazing Masjid  for the sake of Allah in the country of  Norway click on the link and donate now  for the sake of Allah  and to believe all the messengers Yes  except that yes no one is forcing you no  way  okay okay I'll be witness English  that it is none that there is none  worthy of worship worthy of worship but  Allah  and I am a witness and every witness  is his last messages  is his servant  it's his servant and messages  I'm madam  um  read it yeah  Islam net is raising funds to establish  a Masjid and Community Center in Norway  and they urgently need your support this  donation will be a Sada khajari for you  because every person that comes a step  closer to Allah through your donation  you and the shall American award click  the link and donate what you can